tan
うわあああああ
あれから6年の月日が経っ
俺は雑感お兄さんにとミックさんはおじ
おじいさんジジイになった
[音楽]
ん
危ないばい
この日はとミックさんとたくさん喋っていっぱいお酒を飲んば者である彼はあとは寝る
だけなのだ
hey
とりあえずとミックさんが出る部屋にドラを運んだ
フゥーうぅうう
6年も前のことなのできっと彼は
ドラの動画のことなど忘れている頃だろう
[音楽]
とりあえず気づかれないようにカーテンの裏にブラを隠すことに成功した
よっしゃあとはターゲット寝かせるだけである
ブーバーっっ
そんなバイオハザードのゾンビみたいな盗賊があります8コエエねんだっ湯レイヤーを
もはやんだよね
もはやローなにある続力
goo
32歳です
やサービスなんかこれじゃなんだけどこっちが指輪ですよ
なんか何が嫌なんですかじゃあね思われたこれいった
あちこ
5エンドもやろうしん
うわああああっ
いっぱい動力ダキッきゅんでいる
べっとり塗ってください
じゃあお言葉に甘えてはいこれ zooper ねえだろうが
度詰めに吹か増加
寝巻きあるの緑色いるぞあってこれさー
もしかしてそのまま寝れるやつめっちゃ気持ちいいほうができたやつからですね
これを上抜いた方がいいそうですね
な躾おっしゃっ
疲れるんですネッツから3日よく
う
大
じゃあこれ空間きついお姉さん落とせなんだからね尾瀬ジャック
おじいちゃうん
おやすみね
[音楽]
こうして aea の眠りについた木目とみんなやっぱ人間じゃねえよってますよ
おやすみ jg コンビそしてとミックさんと俺は眠りについたのであった
[音楽]
ん
おいでおいで等
ミズノの子
[音楽]
獲物があったラーって
ハートって
a オイニー
tee
[音楽]
星 oooo
ああああああ
tan
[音楽]
降りのドラぼ
ブーバーし